one thing that i feel a little bit
guilty about which is
um i love when you've been on my show
and you're such a gifted actor and
and and people have such great respect
for you and then there was something you
did on my show
um which became a gif and it's quite a
popular gif
or jif i don't know what you want to
call it i never know which one it is a
gift for a gif
but um it's you i think you stood up to
demonstrate something and you're
grinding away i think you were talking
about
maybe your son uh your children
and yes yes and one of them is gyro
and we have this this this is everywhere
uh
on the internet these days we can take a
look at that right now
and um there it is there you are
doing that and i'm sorry
i want to apologize because you are
that's enough that is enough
stop that is enough stop you are the
uh you were the essence of the the sort
of the classically trained
brilliant actor with incredible dignity
and you made a choice in one split
second on my show
and that will be playing 80 years from
now when you leave
this earth and they announce your
passing on the news
you in the background i know i know i
only have myself to blame
i should have known better yes that was
me
demonstrating uh a a a conversation i
had with my uh
young son at the time about the birds
and the bees and
um and now my grandchildren are going to
they'll have they'll have it at your
gravesite years and years from now
they'll have a hologram
of that playing over the stone
trust me uh you're much better off than
i
am i have spent most of my life doing
things just like that so i've created
millions of those the trick with me is i
had no dignity to erode
so that's where i win that's not it's
going to be the reverse
the most dignified thing you've ever
done is what everyone will remember
you for yes thank you and then the least
dignified thing i've ever done is what
that would be remembered
very good it's not fair